caserne de beaufonds vendredi matin à
6h45
le caporal-chef waro vient prendre sa
garde ça y est c'est parti pour 24 100
kg
patrice waro et sapeurs pompiers depuis
30 ans et ici tout le monde l'appelle
coco ce matin il rejoint les douze
hommes et femmes qui forment aujourd'hui
l'effectif de la caserne de saint benoît
l'équipe entrante comme on l'appelle
fait face aux officiers l'équipe
sortante forme le côté c'est l'heure de
la relève alors on va contrôler le fpt
elle
le fpt elle appelé aussi autopompes et
le camion de base des pompiers pour la
lutte contre les incendies et les
secours aux personnes
ça va gratter et non pas les tuyaux
simon fin des mules sur les choses les
plus importants
pour bien vérifier
petit café quelques minutes plus tard
nous retrouvons coco en tenue de sport
quand j'en ai commence comme ça vous
connaît jamais comment il va tourner
on peut aller fait juste pour cinq
minutes et ça m'appartient insultes
qu'hoarau est pompier et sportif qu'il
est vice champion du monde de nage en
eau vive et chaque année il participe à
des compétitions partout dans le monde
sabine pompiers volontaires le rejoint
en attendant la première intervention de
la journée
[Musique]
des débats personne ne répondant pas aux
appels
coco arrive les pompiers sont appelés
pour une intervention à quelques
centaines de mètres de la caserne
alertés par une très forte odeur un
habitant est allé frapper à la porte
d'un voisin et n'a obtenu aucune réponse
dans l'eau passe par ici
l'appartement est situé au premier étage
les pompiers cherchent la meilleure
solution pour y accéder donc à sa porte
d'entrée parce que la fenêtre
sabine emmène le pied de biche et
l'équipe pénètre dans l'immeuble
à ce moment là personne ne sait ce que
l'on va découvrir derrière la porte
fois la personne et allonge temps aux
malades ont apparemment l'appartement
est à l'abandon mais il faut vérifier
toutes les pièces la mauvaise odeur
provenant de la cuisine envahie de
mouches la nourriture avait sans doute
été laissés là depuis plusieurs semaines
après reconnaissance à l'intérieur
aucun cas grave à déplorer
et après les dires des témoins
l'appartement serait occupé par une
personne déficience mentale et voilà ce
sera la seule intervention de la matinée
du coup de retour à la caserne corvée
nettoyage pour tout le monde avant de se
retrouver en cuisine pour peler les
oignons besoins de nos vies à la case
est celle de ma famille bah oui oui
c'est comme à la maison
on est obligé de donner un coup de main
pour faire à manger chacun donne un coup
de main pour faire à manger
la cnds publie ici c'est les hommes qui
cuisinent celle avantage en face des
hans et les âmes à la cuisine c'est ça
qui est bien
voilà trois accusés symbole
12h30 c
c'est l'heure de manger un excellent
rougail saucisses devant un excellent
journal télévisé mais soudain les
discussions cesse
quand le journal évoque l' incendie dans
lequel dix personnes ont perdu la vie la
veille dans le 16e arrondissement de
paris
[Musique]
oh
à partir quoi bertrand françois
le feu était signalé dans le quartier de
la marine mais les pompiers en beau
chercher aucun feu à l'horizon
apparemment les habitants du quartier
ont réussi à éteindre le feu man
la journée s'écoule ainsi sans nouvelle
intervention le métier de pompier est
aussi un métier d'attentes
même s'il en est vendredi que le week
end commence et que la paix et les
allocations sont tombés en ce début de
moins la soirée sera très calme
une seule intervention ce soir pour les
pompiers de saint benoît on signale un
homme couché dans la rue dans le centre
ça y est
ok elle est là et c'est lisa l'homme en
état d'ébriété s'est à présent relever
ne semble pas nécessiter d'assistance
l'équipe décide de repartir à les grog
il est maintenant 22 heures et le
caporal-chef hoarau va tenter de dormir
un peu pendant la guerre dont sur ses
deux oreilles
pas vraiment on essaie de se reposer un
petit peu parce qu'on ne sait pas ce qui
nous attend ce soir donc c'est vraiment
mal l'oreille seul auriez pu écouter la
sonnerie go mais cette nuit-là la
sonnerie ne retentira pas une seule fois
mais dans la nuit tranquille pas une
sortie donc ça va le collectivement rend
service à saint-andré vous dire que cela
foutu un coup à tout le monde
vous y pensez colle à la mort quand vous
partez en intervention côtoyé la mort et
sauver des vies c'est le quotidien de
ces hommes d un tronçon qui nous
manquons des gens qui sont dans la
détresse
les dénis maman
papa août comme la famille du mouty
sauver mon garçon sauvé de l'enfance au
dénouement
et vous vous êtes en train de traiter ça
arrive à chaque round quand le médecin
si c'est ça qui est là qui dit hanté 103
minutes entre hassan ben voilà toute la
détresse de la famille se met à pleurer
là c'est là c'est très délicat et après
des années encore peur mais ça arrive
donc pas fâché quand la nuit est calme
il est 7 heures c'est l'heure de la
relève coco hoarau rentrer chez lui il
reviendra lundi pour un nouveau tour de
garde